well we've been telling you about Texas
troops working around the clock this
Christmas weekend as nearly 17 000
migrants tried crossing the border but
this picture of a rickety boat named
with God's blessing bringing 15 Cuban
refugees to Florida on Christmas morning
proves the crisis at the border is a
problem facing every state Florida GOP
Congressman Carlos Jimenez sits on the
house Homeland Security committee he
joins us now Congressman thank you for
joining us and as we showed with that
boat you had 15 Cubans coming uh to the
keys but this is not an isolated case it
happens every day you see it here what
is your reaction uh to where things
stand with regards to the Border
well now not only do we have a crisis at
the border of the Southern border but
we've seen a four-fold increase in uh in
Crossings uh from Cuba from Haiti you
know into the into Florida especially
the Florida Keys and so
um you know conditions are just you know
really bad on the island it's an
oppressive government uh most Cubans
nowadays though are trying to get
through the southern border it takes
about twenty thousand dollars to get
from Cuba to Nicaragua and then up
through Mexico and then finally in into
the southern border so that's what's
really happening but still many of them
are still trying to cross you know
through the Straits it connection as
Republicans come into power in the
majority in the new year what do you
hope to do about the Border what can you
do
well I think we have we need to have
hearings on why why it is that the
secretary majorca's Department of
Homeland Security refuses really to
secure our Southern border uh it's a not
only a problem with the millions of
migrants that are coming in illegally
into the United States but also it
leaves the Border unprotected and so we
see fentanyl flowing through at record
pace and we know that fentanyl is
responsible for the deaths of tens of
thousands of Americans every single year
so it's an absolute failure of the Biden
Administration and protecting American
and protecting American lives and also
talking about other things that
Republicans may be doing in the house in
the New Year all of these Revelations
about Twitter Intel ties raising
questions about big Tech other sites as
House GOP uh James Comer your colleague
the incoming chairman of the oversight
committee will begin to have these
hearings and in the in the part nine of
the Twitter files that you may have seen
dropped pretty much on Christmas Eve we
learned that there's a foreign Intel
intelligence task force across multiple
government agencies not just the FBI
also CIA the the National Defense
intelligence group not looking at
foreign intelligence but rather at
domestic folks in encouraging censorship
there what stands out to you what do you
uh want to get to most when the hearings
begin
well look it's uh it's no surprise I
mean look I was mayor of Miami-Dade and
and in charge of the one of the largest
police agencies in the United States
Miami-Dade Police Department we did
surveillance on on Twitter and social
media all the time to take a look at
gang activity and all that but we never
try to suppress anything and so
censorship that's the problem you know
you can look at at things uh from a
surveillance standpoint yeah because
it's it's all it's all public but when
you try to start censoring people and
you try to start censoring you know
ideas Etc and then you start putting out
false narratives like the FBI saying
that they needed to censor the hunter
Biden story because it was false
information them knowing very well that
it wasn't because they had the laptop
that's a problem it's to me it's a
violation of the First Amendment freedom
of speech government should not be
involved in trying to censor people and
censor ideas that's very problematic
that needs to be investigated and we
need to get to the bottom of it hey
congressman seconds left there's talk
with Florida being the fastest growing
one should Elon Musk move to the
Sunshine State
absolutely you know I've asked Elon Musk
to move to Florida and Miami-Dade in
particular we have freedom of thought we
it's a great state it's a great free
state of Florida and and you know we've
got thousands of people coming down here
every single day why because it's just a
great state to live in sunshine and
beaches congression Carlos him and us
thank you very much for taking time